[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another Fandango indie movie guide
and as my title said three very twisted
films for you today and each of these
films show a different side to someone's
personality or purpose to personalities
I should say let's start with a film
that I saw at Fantastic Fest Buster's
mal Hart
this is directed by a great new young
female director she's super cool Sarah
Adina Smith and with this film she shows
a whole lot of visual style and
something very unique to say it stars
Rami Malek and he plays off a little bit
of the mr. robot paranoia personality
that we've seen that TV show but he gets
to show a different side to himself so
you see multiple versions of this
character one is Buster he is a crazy
homeless guy living in the mountains
calling up the radio and ranting about
the end of the world
you also see Jonah this very responsible
family man who is working grueling night
shifts at a hotel to try to make enough
money to support his family and then it
all comes to a head when a stranger
comes into the hotel I can help you I
need the room
and the last free man like I know you
everything these days is going to trap
them in eternal records of the almost
thing over and over again are you okay
there's some scary moments there's some
touching moments and sad moments and I
think rami malek shows how charismatic
he is and how you really want to follow
him in any character he plays I had a
good time watching this film it's one of
those puzzling movies that then you'll
think about over and over again
afterwards and try to work it out in
your head busters now Hart is in limited
theaters this weekend but if you want
something to watch at home might I
recommend tickled I've talked about this
documentary before one of my favorite
films I saw last year it's from New
Zealand
directed by Dylan Reeve and it's all
about David Ferriero who is a journalist
often looking at the weird and wacky
stories and news he comes across a story
about a competitive tickling team and he
decides to investigate it but it is not
what it seems and soon there is a whole
nother side to the story the thing that
she hates the most was no it was like a
bomb went off your phone number and your
personal information are entirely known
and subject to publication on the
internet all hell broke loose it goes
down a very very dark rabbit hole that
you wouldn't expect just from looking at
the title tickled it sounds really fun
and silly but it's fascinating it keeps
you on the edge of your seat the whole
way through and if you like tickled then
make sure you see the tickle King which
is a follow up and they probably should
do another follow up with what's
happened
you see study my god oh my god
check out tickles it's available on
video on demand and DBZ this week and a
film that you can watch right now on
Fandango now is split hey pardon me
sorry thank you of their own car this
film made a lot of money when it was
released earlier this year it's from M
night Shyamalan who did The Sixth Sense
and he started sort of dropping off
after that he got used to doing this big
twist ending and it just became very
stale and we won't even talk about the
happening but here he is back James
McAvoy plays a guy who suffers from
multiple personality disorder now
usually that is not at all a dangerous
disorder but here in this context of the
movie he has 23 personalities and it's
the 24th but they have to be worried
about these girls that he kidnapped I
think given the restrictions of a
smaller budget M night Shyamalan had to
keep the story contained and James
McAvoy he is a brilliant actor as he's
shown time and time again he always
gives his all to every movie he does but
here doing the all the different
personalities how it's impressive
you can rent or buy it on Fandango now
right now he's done awful things to
people and he'll do all whole things for
you it's a twisty turny week but each of
those films are hashtag Alicia approved
so I recommend you go to the theaters if
you can to see Buster's mal Hart
or buy the DVD of pickles and go on to
Fandango now calm and rent or buy switch
I know I'm very happy person and I'm
always smiling but I really enjoy a dark
into serving film in the comments below
let me know if you've seen any of those
films or what you've enjoyed watching
lately you can also find me on Twitter
at Alicia Malone next week I'm going to
be at the Overlook Film Festival for
some more dark horror twisty turny
movies so I will be taking you there
along with me for the ride so that's
next week and I'll see you then bye
you